(upbeat music)
(hockey sticks hitting)
- [Marissa] When we were younger,
I never thought I looked
any different than her.
- [Hannah] And we didn't understand
why people would be like,
"Are you actually sisters?"
We were like, "Yeah, obviously."
(upbeat music)
(sticks hitting puck)
- My name's Hannah Brandt,
and I play for Team USA.
- My name's Marissa Brandt, and
I play for Team South Korea.
- And we're sisters.
- [Marissa] I was born
in Seoul, South Korea,
and I was adopted when
I was four months old.
I flew on a plane to the States
and that's where I met my parents.
I started playing hockey when I was eight.
And you started...
- I started when I was
about five years old.
- [Marissa] We did everything
together growing up,
so really I chose hockey just
to be able to be with her,
but as I got older, I really
learned to love this sport.
- [Hannah] We've played
together through high school
and then we went our
separate ways for college.
When we're on opposite ends of the world.
- [Marissa] Everyday we
talk and text and ask
about how each other's days
went and games and whatnot
so yeah, I mean being so far
away we stay connected somehow.
(crowd cheers)
- [Hannah] I think it's a super cool thing
that we're both going to the Olympics,
playing for different teams and in
the same sport I don't
know how common that is
so I think it makes it that
much more special for us
but I think for our family and friends,
that they have two teams to root for.
Just so happy to be able to
continue to play the sport
I love and be able to go to
the Olympics with this one.
(happy music)
- [Marissa] Hockey has
shaped and influenced both
of our lives growing up so I
can't imagine a better reason
to be able to go back to my
home country, through hockey.
- [Hannah] For me going to
the Olympics has kinda always
been a dream of mine and then to be able
to watch my sister do the same thing
and to be able to go
through this experience
with her is just a dream come true.
(happy music)